is it your position that the
constitution
provides for some heretofore invisible
right to an abortion regardless of what
you think about the issue
it is my opinion that we have a right to
privacy and abortion is a medical
procedure and the right to privacy does
extend to the discussions between a
patient and a medical provider okay but
i could have a right to privacy with my
mafia capo and we could decide to whack
my political enemy and those i guess
those conversations would be private i
don't think there is some generalized
right to privacy in the constitution but
even if they were that would have no
bearing on the life of the person that
we're going to kill right
well the discussion between you and your
mafia friend is very different from a
discussion between a patient and a
medical provider we have laws that
protect patient privacy for this exact
reason but but i suppose you're right
the distinction is that right now it's
illegal for me to talk to my mafia boss
and call out a hit on someone i don't
like and it is legal right now at least
according to the civil law for a woman
to talk to a doctor and kill her child
but that very likely will not remain
legal if roe versus weight is overturned
in 13 14 states instantly that will
become illegal so i guess i'm just
talking about the matter itself beyond
questions of the civil law which might
be changing in real time right now
what's the difference if if you're
saying it's all about a right to privacy
i'm saying no it's about the baby that's
being killed so do you have an answer
for that or we just deny the humanity of
the baby
no absolutely so when you put up a
scenario of trying to put out a hit
with the mafia you are talking about
murdering a born living conscious
sentient autonomous person when we talk
about abortion we are talking about
ending a
non-autonomous life it does you do not
have the right to bodily autonomy if you
are not autonomous and if you are a
fetus prior to the limit of viability
you do not have autonomy therefore you
do not have the right to bodily autonomy
this is a great way
you reside inside of the body of an
autonomous person and the right to
bodily autonomy allows you to refuse to
use your body to support the life of
another person so
this is a precise and important point
you've made you've acknowledged that
abortion ends a life but you've said
those were your exact words you just
said that the life is not autonomous
would you say that a uh
two-day-old
post-birth baby is autonomous
it is it has bodily autonomy and it's
able its body system is able to function
autonomously yes
the baby can feed it
you are trying to get to the point where
they require external resources but any
person can provide that infant external
resources the utilization of someone's
internal organs is very different from
providing external resources you cannot
force someone to be a parent and provide
external resources you can give up that
child at any point that you stop
consenting to your parental
responsibilities in your parental rights
okay so that's fine so so we've
acknowledged now that the baby is is
living in the womb or outside the womb
it's a living being and that the baby is
it's not really auton and maybe it has
it it's not attached by an umbilical
cord but it certainly doesn't have
autonomy when it's two days old it needs
to it needs to eat it needs everything
taken care of for it what you're saying
is though once the umbilical cord has
been severed the baby can be taken care
of by someone else so then my question
is
why would we not merely encourage
adoption if the mother feels she can't
take care of the baby why not just give
up the baby for adoption rather than
killing the baby in the womb
because pregnancy and itself is a very
serious medical condition that has
physical mental emotional and financial
burdens for the pregnant person and to
force a person to endure that experience
against their will is simply immoral and
it's belittling the experience that
pregnancy is well so when you say
against their will what you are you're
referring to cases of rape basically
right because well when you engage in
sex you are engaging in an act of the
will the consequence of which is
historically speaking always pregnancy
correct but when you consent to sex
you're not consenting to pregnancy you
are consenting to the possibility of
pregnancy but you can think of it like
this you can think of it like this you
understand the difference between
consensual sex and sexual sexual assault
you should then understand the
difference between wanted pregnancy and
unwanted pregnancy technically
physically they are the same thing but
when your body is being used against
your will and without your consent those
are very different experiences for the
person but
you you've just acknowledged that when
you consent to sex you are consenting to
the possibility of pregnancy so
there you have it there you are you have
consented to that now you might not want
to become pregnant you might want to use
all sorts of contraceptives and things
like that but surely i mean you've just
said it yourself you're consenting to
that possibility and so now you're
telling me that if one wants to then
withdraw one's consent because one
doesn't want to be uncomfortable for
some matter of months you're saying that
the the better alternative is to just
kill the baby whom you have acknowledged
is alive
first of all calling pregnancy simply
discomfort is belittling the experience
but you can always
if you have a uterus
a man with a uterus michael
look i'm not a biologist so i'm not sure
if i'll become pregnant i do have a
little emoji that tells me that these
days men can become pregnant regardless
regardless of that
if you're talking about non-consensual
sex what percentage of pregnancies arise
from rape incest or involve a threat to
the life of the mother well it's hard to
say because about three quarters of
sexual assault go unreported so any
statistic that i would give to you is
going to be inherently enacted i'll give
you a statistic a statistic from the the
most left-wing source i can give the
guttmacher institute it's the think tank
for planned parenthood less than one
percent of abortions take place because
of rape and sister pose a threat to the
life of the mother so we're talking
about it extraordinarily the ones that
have been reported according to the ones
that have been reported don't you think
don't you think if there were don't you
think if there were a scarier statistic
that the most pro abortion organization
in the country might use those
statistics
but these statistics are very difficult
to collect because again sexual assault
is a difficult issue when people don't
often report them because you see how
our political system doesn't often
support victims of sexual assault and so
if our system doesn't support people
reporting sexual assault therefore it is
under-reported so
this seems difficult for me bronte well
one it seems that in the years after the
metoo movement there is quite a great
political impulse to report sexual
assault and all sorts of sexual issues
but furthermore you're telling me that
we need to rely on these statistics
trust the science trust the public
health organizations when it's
convenient for your argument and
convenient for abortion but we shouldn't
trust this statistics when it's
inconvenient for your argument argument
and supports the pro-life argument
that is incorrect you simply don't
understand how these statistics work and
how they are collected when you
understand when you now analyze
statistics you have to understand the
bias and the flaws that they have and
what you are specifically citing
statistics that have inherent flaws that
doesn't mean that all of the statistics
that we cite are inherently flawed you
have to understand the issue at hand and
how those statistics are collected okay
fair enough so so you're saying you just
you don't believe these statistics that
are inconvenient but you say you have
perfectly good reason not to believe the
statistics i suppose the question though
is really beyond the statistics isn't it
if you are acknowledging bronte that
the baby is alive if you are
acknowledging that the baby could be
given up for adoption if you are
acknowledging that instances of rape are
i think we can acknowledge they're quite
rare at least when we're talking about
even if you dispute some of the
statistics they're they're the exception
not the rule
if you are acknowledging all sorts of if
you are acknowledging the relatively low
maternal mortality rate if you are
acknowledging
the advancements in in science if you
are acknowledging that very very few
women die every year from illegal
abortions and uh all sorts of the other
scare statistics that come out if you're
acknowledging all of those numbers even
beyond that
don't don't we still have the fact of
the baby don't we still have the
non-utilitarian non-statistical simple
fact that you're talking about a living
human being
no so first off you said that we have a
low mortality rate which actually we
have one of the highest maternal
mortality rates amongst all of the
developed countries but it's still quite
what's what is the maternal mortality
right according to this i don't know it
off the top of my head 20 out of 20 out
of 100 000 and that and that includes
communities that do not have very good
public health outcomes because of
various behaviors and pathologies in the
community so it's relatively quite low
how many women died from illegal
abortion the year before roe versus wade
i'm not sure but that's besides the
point 39 women